all day I dream about scientifically
figuring out how to make a time machine
in which we could either jump I had four
years from this current moment or back
about a year year and a half and really
done more hi guys I'm very telling do
you not know now you know your life is
different now things suck in the world
currently what I like to do with any
negative energy I have is channel it
into home decor some might say that I'm
using interior design to repress or
avoid real feelings I'm having but I say
no I'm not and stop looking at me like
that
is my Amazon Prime here oh my god so
about that my Amazon Prime now order
just came which is relevant to this
video so I need some sort of shelving
system in my bedroom and I'm feeling
angry about the order that the world is
in right now I decided to channel that
into some unique interior design looking
up shelves online earlier today and I
found on Pottery Barn Teen this shelving
really it's cute it spells out the words
love and I thought oh that's interesting
if I spell out a word using shelves on
my wall so I bought some shows from Ikea
earlier and I'm like one shelf short for
what I want to try to make because they
didn't have enough of the shelves and
dock all those quickly found out after
the fact that the shelves weren't sold
with screws so thank you Amazon also I
got this with a funnel Maj because like
four or five years ago I made a video in
my old apartment in Brooklyn before
going to LA just getting drunk and put a
shelves up with you guys next and this
is the key to most DIY at home
renovation is about to break let's do it
again shall we
I'm Wow hi welcome to this big space so
here's my television here's like the
really big kind of nightstand setup I
have for my cable box so that's why I
want to put a unique wall shelving thing
here it was no idea what to do that in
order to house the cable box but when I
actually looked up how much weight each
one of these shelves holds like a third
of the weight at two bucks
duffle whoopee these are the shelves I'm
using they're called black or yellow
I was going to go for white but I got
yellow because it just has the most
amount of shells left I laid out my
design on the floor sort of I could go
to of it but I didn't really measure
anything nor did I really think this
through it would happen
everything here designer knows that
before you even start playing any holes
in the wall that's a break cheers feels
like gerrae
I got to do this and we can't find my
level anywhere though I downloaded a
level app on my phone
are you a disadvantage no I shot myself
oh I guess here's what you'll need for
this DIY shell bruise and anchor screw
driver or thrilled and sloppy semblance
of an idea and I kind of hope that were
to be screws and anchors Amazon Prime
down like I said earlier and it came
with two drill bit which is great cuz
actually needed then the droven came
with them so read on the tips of them is
that normal into someone's blood it
seems very very aggressive even for a
power tool or maybe any other color to
show you which one is the tip oh I just
was going to cut a head don't worry the
first letter took a really long time and
definitely can't hold anything on it
keeps on trying status everything sucks
and this is way harder and sucks would
you like a close-up look oh here's the
state of our wall we have kind of a
letter that's very not actually level at
all and then let go at it measuring hole
feeling great really relieving all the
stress
okay we're done we're done we're down
dispel this felon we're done in three
hours
hey there's so much I hate it so much I
have so much rage this is the work no
it's not there's worse things this was
supposed to be my respite from the worst
things that are happening in the world
you couldn't tell the writing is gonna
spell doors but how ironic that I
couldn't get this dubbing work it's a
quick reminder to like don't stop being
creative but also like really know your
limits should just go on and yet scene
found a shelf that looks like this
hopefully my failure has allowed you
some break from whatever nonsense is
happening in the rest of the world I'm
going to go
scream into a pillow you guys like this
video don't we give it thumbs up and a
quick boost button to subscribe to the
YouTube channel I'm always here to make
you feel better about your abilities and
your choices uh underscore I don't know
it was work had I known when I can't let
me give you just come see the
catastrophic damage to wall
oh there's fun friends and then we come
Pammy we tried so many holes that's what
he said nothing is going to be able to
do nothing will be able to be on any of
this boy